[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
waiting over an hour for tea sounds
ridiculous
shocking even but this isn't your
everyday tea what they're waiting for is
cheese tea
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cheese tea is exactly what it sounds
like tea topped with cheese
[Music]
juice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
and today cheese tea is more than just a
novelty it's gone global from malaysia
to los angeles people are drinking it
everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
on the italian island of sardinia there
is a delicacy that has been consumed for
thousands of years
it is known as the world's most
dangerous cheese
yeah you heard right
[Music]
meet simone eba a third generation sheep
farmer
producer
[Music]
literally means rotten cheese and it's
not for the faint of heart because this
cheese is infested with thousands of
live maggots
and while that might seem a bit
off-putting at first it's the maggots
that give the cheese its distinctive
texture and flavor
here's how it works
first a traditional wheel of pecorino
cheese is made from sheep's milk
then a special fly called a cheese fly
is allowed to lay its eggs in it
[Music]
over the course of two to three months
the maggots eat the cheese and then
excrete it out again transforming it
into the soft and creamy kasu
[Music]
gusto
[Music]
today it's a favorite for special
occasions like weddings and birthday
parties but eating this cheese can be
dangerous
even though cases like this are
extremely rare it's risky enough that
the cheese is illegal to sell but
farmers like simone continue to make it
for themselves
[Music]
and they just can't get enough for
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
black
[Music]
sixteen years ago slobodan seamish
bought a dozen donkeys his herd has
since grown to nearly 300
but hundreds of donkeys doesn't
necessarily mean gallons of donkey milk
unlike cows or goats donkeys produce
milk in very small quantities while
nursing their fall
[Music]
so he tried to make cheese from his
donkey milk but it turns out that
process was far from simple problems
so he keeps his methods a secret
[Music]
the cheese goes for around 500 a pound
and it has a rich nutty and earthy
flavor it is known to be quite filling
but just a select few have tasted it you
can only get donkey cheese in serbia
[Music]
is
[Music]
let's say you're a cheese producer and
you need a loan because you want to buy
a tractor or food for your cows or
really just about anything there's a
bank in italy that will take your cheese
and give you cash this is the story of
three men and millions of dollars worth
of cheese
meet mauro
he's a cheese producer in the emiliano
region of italy he produces parmigiano
reggiano the so called king of cheese
[Music]
20 000 wheels holy cow that's a lot of
cheese
when mauro or another cheese producer in
this part of italy needs a loan they go
to credito emiliano a big italian bank
and like any bank credit emiliano needs
collateral for their loan
and to do that he talks to fausto ciao
he works for credits
parmigiano-reggiano is a special kind of
cheese because it needs to be aged for
18 to 36 months and a wheel can be worth
thousands of dollars making it a safe
long-term investment for the bank
addiction
program
to be clear the bank doesn't store the
valuable cheese in its vaults next to
gold bars and stacks of cash they have a
special cheese warehouse down the road
filled with thousands and thousands of
wheels of cheese that's where roberto
comes in he's the general director of
the tagliate general warehouses that's
where credito emiliano stores their
cheese
roberto and his team take care of more
than 300 000 wheels of cheese that's
currently worth more than 160 million
euros
without proper care cheese could lose
its value
produce
[Music]
sounds to me like the cow the bank and
the cheese are in good hands
[Music]
fondue it's this thing we do with cheese
we melt it we dip it we eat it in the
70s it became super popular but that
didn't just happen by chance there was
an ominous force behind it a real life
cheese cartel
[Music]
a hundred years ago cheese was a hot
commodity in switzerland it was exported
at high volumes and played a major role
in the swiss economy but that all
changed after world war one european
countries devastated by the war could no
longer afford to buy expensive imported
cheese which was bad news for
switzerland so the government stepped in
and they formed the cheese union
basically it was a cartel and it worked
like this
the first thing they did was force every
dairy farmer and cheese monger to fix
the price of cheese eliminating
competition meaning everyone could stay
in the game the cheese cartel also told
them exactly how much cheese to make and
limited the varieties so instead of
making thousands of different kinds of
cheese they only made seven and it
worked the cartel controlled the cheese
supply for decades
by the 70s they got greedy and wanted to
expand their cheese racket globally so
they introduced the world to a dish
already popular in the freezing cold
alps fondue by marketing cheese for
fondue the cartel was able to sell more
i mean think about it it takes a lot and
i mean a lot of cheese to fill a pot but
as with most cartels things got shady
money went missing people went to jail
and by the 1990s the swiss cheese union
was dismantled so there you have it the
reason we know and love fondue is
because of a shady government program
that convinced the world to consume
massive amounts of melted cheese
[Music]
you